anytime something happens it feels like
it's beyond our control the knee-jerk is
we need more government as if government
is going to solve things government
naturally doesn't do that it's the
opposite it's just layers and layers of
suffocating bureaucracy that that
collapses under the weight of its own
good intentions hey hey welcome this is
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special I'm
really excited to welcome to the program
today American political commentator
radio personality and the host of
Kennedy at 9:00 p.m. on the Fox Business
Network Kennedy thanks so much for
stopping by and it is so nice to be here
well I'm really excited that we're in
New York and actually that's great yes
and we brought the New York vibe so well
done Oh perfect okay so it's dingy and
horrifying okay perfect
so for folks who don't actually know
your backgrounds you know a really
interesting background because you know
I was political from a very young age
but you were a music person right you
were you're a VJ on on MTV so how did
you get into that in the first place uh
the the things that I loved most in high
school were music and politics and I
didn't graduate from high school I
didn't get a diploma so my parents
didn't want me to just linger in
Portland so they gave me money they they
paid me to leave and I moved to Los
Angeles to get into political consulting
because that's naturally where people go
and I ended up getting an internship at
a radio station really great radio
station KROQ and my boss there Andy
Schon
I used to go into his office once a week
as an intern there's an unpaid intern
and ask him to put me on the air and
eventually once he did and so he gave me
an audition and I got to do overnights
and then I worked on Kevin and bean and
then Andy was hired at MTV as a senior
vice president programming and they
needed new VJs and he got me an audition
and they hired me which was crazy and
even he admits that he couldn't believe
that they hired someone with absolutely
no television experience so first of all
I'm now having serious deja vu because I
think that I probably listen to you
growing up in LA that's really funny on
k-rock driving back and forth to school
yeah because even though that wasn't my
particular channel the
welcome 106.7 so that met is really
really funny so okay so I get into
critiques of alternative rock I've
already gotten into trouble for critics
of rap so I have to get into critiques
of alternative rock a little bit later
on in the program but how did you make
the transition from you're an MTV VJ to
the world of politics it's a pretty
radical shift I was really into politics
when I got to MTV and I self-identified
as a conservative Republican and of
course it was the beginning of the
Clinton era so Bill Clinton was
obviously elected in November of 1992 I
started in MTV in September of that year
and so the chooser Lu's campaign was on
its maiden voyage and it was very
political time and you know there was
this undercurrent that we needed change
and younger voices and I always felt
that the younger voices were
disproportionately represented by the
left unchallenged mostly and I was
already a skeptic and I didn't really
have a name for my political philosophy
I just knew it ran counter to the
groupthink and what people were spouting
that I felt was very spoon-fed with very
little critical thought and I was
interested in politics and I loved
Ronald Reagan and was obsessed with Dan
Quayle and I was sad to see the the
first Bush presidency and because that
meant that J Danforth Quayle the third
went with them so how did people treat
you being a conservative in the music
industry I mean being at k-rock I can't
imagine there were lots of lots of folks
over there at the time who are who are
very Pro conservative I mean this is
days of Jimmy Kimmel one day they
weren't it was actually before Jimmy
John yeah before Jamie and Adam but they
people were curious and it was a
Republican in Southern California was a
very funny thing it was a very like Palm
Springs Country Club and obviously I
didn't fit that mold so I wasn't a
typical cookie cutter I want to hate you
Republican and I like debating with
people and you know for that people were
by and large more curious and you know
people would make fun of me I remember
the first time I met
Denis Leary he was just relentlessly
making funny music you were Republican
in your name's Kennedy it's a dumbest
thing I've ever heard
and there was more discussion whereas
now we didn't have canceled culture and
you know people really took in
information in longer form whereas you
know now it's really a mousse bouche
that's all of what social media is and
so you had a little bit more room to
defend yourself in your positions
whereas now and I talked to Pat smear a
little bit about this in my book from
the germs and Nirvana and of course Foo
Fighters and he said that if I tried to
come out as a Republican today on MTV I
first of all wouldn't have been hired
and the second that was sort of
nationally consumed I would have been
fired or dismissed pretty quickly so
didn't graduate from high school and
then you were telling me that you went
to college yeah when you were 28 yeah
which is not usually when people go now
it's a great time to go though because
after you've worked a little bit and you
know you've tried your hand at a few
careers you figure out that you have
gaps in knowledge and you also figure
out what you want to do and what you
want to focus your time on because by
the time you get further into adulthood
you realize that your times a little bit
more precious and you don't have quite
as much energy and you're also not as
worried you don't you're not consumed by
the same kind of anxiety you are when
you're in your late teens and early 20s
where everything has to be immediate and
you have to get it done and so much of
that is forced and so I found when I
went to college late I only wanted to
study what I wanted to study and not
what someone projected on me that I
should study like communications or
business that it sounded very very
boring to me and so I started with
history and philosophy and I really
liked both of those and I also studied a
lot of physics and science I realized if
I were going to get if I were going to
major in physics it would have taken two
years of just math before I got to any
of my lower division classes so
philosophy it was because every time I
took a philosophy class I loved it more
and more no matter what the subject
matter was and I really loved ancient
Greek philosophy and philosophy
of science and I found that the two of
them were asking the same kind of
existential questions and oftentimes
those are unanswerable and you know for
people who love philosophy that's fine
like the fact that you're never really
going to get to a terminus is acceptable
because what you find along the way what
you uncover isn't it itself very
satisfying okay so I want to ask about
what you did after after college and how
you end up at Fox Business Network
because that's a hell of a transition in
I'm gonna ask in one second but first
September is National Life Insurance
Awareness Month
most people aren't aware of that in fact
you weren't until I just said it but 40%
of Americans don't actually have life
insurance
getting life insurance doesn't need to
be difficult or expensive right now
prices are the lowest they've been in 20
years and policy genius has made it
easier than ever to get covered policy
genius is the easy way to shop for life
insurance online in just minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home insurance auto insurance and
disability insurance if you need life
insurance but you just haven't gotten
around to it because it's awkward and
weird to think about
go get your life insurance right now
because national life insurance month is
here so just do it go to policy genius
com get quotes apply in minutes you can
do the whole thing on your phone right
this very instant policy genius it's the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance again go to policy genius.com
and go get the life insurance that you
and your family need policy genius
alrighty so let's talk about what you
did after after you were at UCLA so you
have UCLA and you're in history and
philosophy and you're out of the music
industry now yes so after MTV I moved to
Seattle and did talk radio and then I
moved to LA and did more talk radio and
that's when I started going to college
and hosted a couple of game shows on
game show network which is the best job
no one should ever make fun of game
shows are games realist because it is
such an amazing job and it's such a
positive optimistic environment because
people who are watching they want to
watch and they really believe that they
can achieve something in a short amount
of time and a game show fans and
gamblers are cut from the same cloth and
I really
that cloth and then when I went to Santa
Monica College and UCLA I started doing
a little bit more talk radio and then
did kind of a talk soup for reality TV
meanwhile in 1993 I had met Roger Ailes
at politically-incorrect at one of the
very first episodes of politically
incorrect when it was on Comedy Central
and I had a copy of this book that he
signed and then I met him a few times
when I was at Fox reality channel and in
2000 or sorry in 1999 I wrote an advice
book for girls and I went on Bill
O'Reilly's show to promote it and Bill
O'Reilly attacked me and I couldn't
figure out why because here's this like
very conservative advice that I'm giving
like you know don't drink don't have sex
before you're married I interviewed a
nun and O'Reilly attacking me about
something like you're so stupid but then
I met with Roger who was like we would
like you to come work at Fox one day I'm
like I just moved to Seattle that's not
gonna happen
and then 2001 started college did vh1's
best week ever which was like a clip
show where comics and journalists
comments on various pop culture stories
and that's what put me through college
and then afterward I had to start
working and then I got a job at KFI
which is a talk radio station in Los
Angeles and I really found my political
voice doing talk radio in Seattle which
was an interesting place because there's
the dichotomy of the ultra liberals in
Seattle and then a lot of conservatives
libertarians and survivalists in the
outskirts and in the rest of Washington
State and I felt like those were my
people and and I really enjoyed the
natural tension and found more of my
voice on KFI when I left UCLA so what
has happened to rock it seems like for a
while there was the hot thing among high
schoolers I remember I was in high
school everybody was listening to that
except for me what did you listen to
music hey you got it I was I was a
classical violinist from the time I was
five and my dad national piano so we
grew up doing that so I didn't have I
would say proper appreciation for
alternative rock I probably still do not
since all of my references ended about
19:20 but but what do you think has
happened to the alternative rock scene
it seems like pop has eaten everything
in sort of the rock sphere it has and
and that's okay because every generation
consumes and expresses music differently
and they should be able to do that but I
will say to the most brilliant kind of
modern in the bench appear oh spectrum
modern musicians Trent Reznor and Scott
Ian from anthrax
they are both inspired by jazz and
classical music and I remember driving I
was going snowboarding with Scott Ian
and he he was we were listening to
classical music and he said this is so
much more hardcore than any hardcore
music and he was like you know listen to
the chord structure listen to how the
music and the tempo how it changes he's
like you couldn't get away with
structure like this even in hard rock
and and I thought that was really great
how you know these musicians were taking
in music that probably would be
considered contradictory to what they
were putting out and they were deeply
inspired by it and you know I always
think people sound really fast when
they're like well back in my day we had
Nevada but I listened to a lot of music
on Sirius XM I love all nation and you
know my my daughter's are now 10 and 14
and they listen to their own music like
I've tried playing them Beastie Boys and
Ruka salt and they're like blah blah
blah they have no time for it which is
an outrage but they find their own stuff
and everyone has to find the music that
resonates within them I believe it was
Pythagoras who said that maybe you can
educate me a little bit and one of the
things that I've been big on and I just
had discussion with a rapper named zoobi
about about rapping one of the things
that I suggested to him is that as
somebody who grew up in the classical
tradition where skill was was greatly
prized you know one of my problems with
rap is I'm not sure that I see the skill
always first and foremost from from some
of the rappers but there are certain
rock musicians who really know their
stuff so who do you think are the best
musicians in that
manveer in rock oh gosh that's a great
question I mean I really like I really
like drummers like I'm always fascinated
by the the parts that you don't really
pay attention to and there's there's a
duo well that kind of a trio because
they do have an American singer called
Mike snow and they're Swedish and
there's no no one in the band is named
Mike and I think their stuff is really
interesting and I like the way they use
percussion and you know it's like the
marriage of a melody that makes you feel
something and a beat that actually moves
you and then words that make you cry
it's so difficult to get all of those
elements together and when people do it
I think it's such a high art form so I
promise final Rock questions so well if
you have to say name your top three
bands who are they oh that's a great
question I feel like it changes a little
bit my favorite band of all time is a
punk rock band from San Diego called
rocket from the Crypt and if you had a
rocket from the Crypt tattoo in the 90s
and early 2000s you got into their shows
for free and and they're the best shows
I've ever seen in my life a rock from
the clip shows whether it's CBGB's or
Khyber Pass I went and saw them in
Australia and they're amazing I love The
Shins
I love James Mercer I think he's one of
those people he's got such incredible
vocal range and he's got such a melodic
voice and his songs are so honest and
sad and sometimes they're very opaque
and and sometimes they're very
transparent and I think that he has a
beautiful artistry and and then you know
I I love Interpol so do you think that
the year of the music video is dead so
is it MTV killing the radio star and now
it seems like MTV doesn't even broadcast
music videos all that much no I think
shareholders killed the radiostar
when I was at MTV that's when they first
started experimenting with long-form
programming was really in 1992 with the
real world and when that took off they
realized because the rest of the day was
Video Music Day parts and my boss Andy
was the one who dropped it up and said
okay well let's do MTV Jams you MTV raps
MTV Rock's alternative nation and sort
of segmented it throughout the day so if
you
a rap fan you would watch you MTV raps
and MTV Jams and if you liked arm B and
then alternative nation was on every
night at midnight and but they realized
when they started inserting long-form
programming and people were watching for
longer periods of time because after
three minutes if you didn't like the
next music video you would leave the
difference was then there really wasn't
any place to go but now you know I watch
how my girls consume media and it's
mostly YouTube and tik-tok and they I
don't think they've at least in my
presence they've never watched them do
you mean they really don't watch TV
anymore unless I make them watch a
Yankees game say let's talk about
politics because I'm sure that my
political audience is many of them are
interested in the music but I think that
probably they're they're more interested
in your politics so you went from being
sort of a self-described conservative in
opposition to Democrats in the LA area
to being a libertarian how did you
realize that you were a libertarian and
not just sort of a straight line
conservative so it was really
interesting because I didn't know what
it meant to be a libertarian I really
didn't know what the word meant and you
know one night I was having dinner with
Kurt Loder and Kurt was a really great
mentor because he was very honest and
salty and didn't have time for a lot of
people but we developed a really great
friendship and we would talk about
politics and you know he rail against
statism and he would rail against the
Clintons
but at the same time he didn't have
patience for social conservatism and I
was like you know this is really a thing
and what he was telling me resonated and
he was like you're a libertarian and he
gave me a copy of Ayn Rand's Objectivist
epistemology and then I met Penn
Jillette at the MTV studios and Penn is
one of those people who has the most
incredible memory he can remember he's
one of those very few people who can
remember every single day of his life
and so he sent me an email last year and
he's like on this day we recorded the
MTV special in October 1993 I'm like how
do you know that it was incredible to me
and he also was like okay this is what
it means to be a libertarian and and I
was like
I that makes so much more sense to me
but it required more of an investigation
you know what does this mean so it was
almost a conclusion that I had arrived
at half blind and then it took time to
really illuminate what that meant and
and what that meant to me and how my
personal feelings and beliefs interacted
with a hyper rationalism so when it
comes to libertarianism people from the
outside tendency libertarianism is a
very specific sort of mentality but the
fact is that there's a lot of variation
within kind of strains of libertarianism
yeah I know libertarians who are
pro-life I know libertarians who are
more hawkish on foreign policy I know a
libertarians who have very different
views on the size and scope of what
government should actually be involved
in so what's your view of what is the
role of government in American life I
think that we have way too much
government and we need to stop making
excuses why we need more and that's
become a real knee-jerk reaction for
people anytime something happens and it
feels like it's beyond our control
whether personally or culturally the
knee-jerk is we need more government as
if government is going to solve things
or make things better or streamline
things or do a better job of taking pare
taking care of people who are most most
vulnerable because government naturally
doesn't do that it's the opposite it's
just layers and layers of suffocating
bureaucracy that that collapses under
the weight of its own good intentions
and I think there are people whom I
consider to be status who want to expand
the size of government and they have
good intentions like they say they want
to take care of people the problem is
they don't take the longer view of
unintended consequences and I think
that's my biggest issue particularly
with this newest phase of socialism and
it's very unapologetic you know because
growing up as a kid my mom left Romania
they left and came over on a boat when
the commies took their hemp farm and if
you have ancestors or parents who
escaped Eastern Europe and that way
there's something in your bones that
no is really repelled and you can't
stand the communism and it's just it's
baked into your personal casserole and I
always felt that way and so to have
people talk about how great the
collective in the the state and
communism is because that's essentially
the conclusion that they come to I find
it's deeply offensive Joan a second I
want to ask you if there has to be a
contrast between social conservatism and
libertarianism I asked about that in one
second first during times of emergency
sometimes you're going to go to the
grocery store and everything is going to
be sold out and the government
recommends that if there's some sort of
natural disaster or some sort of
emergency that you have some food at
home
well wise company takes an innovative
approach in providing dependable simple
affordable freeze-dried food for
emergency preparedness and outdoor use
wise company meals they're designed to
protect your most valuable asset your
family when government resources are
strained it could be days if not weeks
before you can get to fresh food and
water you can't really rely on someone
else you have to rely on yourself you
know who says this the government you
can't know what tomorrow may bring but
you can't have peace of mind knowing
that you'll be ready with everything you
need there's no better time to prepare
than right now wise emergency food is an
investment in peace of mind for your
family this week my listeners can get
any wise emergency or outdoor food
product at an extra 25 percent off the
lowest mark price at wise food storage
comm / Shapiro plus shipping is free
Wise has a 90 day no questions asked
return policy so there's no risk in
taking the initiative get yourself and
your family more prepared today that's
wise food storage calm / Shapiro to get
any wise emergency or outdoor food
products at an extra 25% off and free
shipping pretty great deal wise food
storage comm okay so let's talk about
the the maybe mutual exclusion or maybe
not of social conservatism in
libertarianism so I consider myself a
libertarian when it comes to government
but I'm a social conservative when it
comes to my own personal values and my
religious values the way that I square
this is I say that basically you do need
a very strong social fabric in order to
support the bulwark of libertarianism
meaning that people have a natural
tendency that when the government fails
to do something they think that the
government ought to that when when
things fall through the cracks they want
a collective to pick up the pieces
normally in the past that collective has
existed in the form of social fabric so
churches
and synagogues particularly tended to
pick up a lot of that slack someone in
your community was suffering you and
your friends went together and helped
them out and this is still true in you
know synagogues like mine where if
somebody is suffering we all get
together they had basically and we pass
it around and so we funded funded this
and then there is a strain of
libertarianism that seems very anti
religious in nature yeah it says that
religion is is deeply destructive to not
just American life but human life in
general that that it's the opiate of the
masses in almost Marxist sort of way and
in terms of its description of religion
how do you see the the social fabric and
the religious social fabric squaring
with libertarianism I think that the
religious social fabric and government
are completely separate and as a
believer I think that we are naturally
designed to worship a creator and you
know obviously in human experience that
takes on many forms I happen to be an
Eastern Orthodox Christian and I
remember talking to my priest as I was
studying philosophy and he was very
worried for me that you know not that he
didn't want me to study because the
Eastern Church is academically very
rigorous and you know some of the most
beautiful and profound writings that
I've read about transubstantiation and
belief and the nature of the soul come
from Eastern Orthodox monks who spend
time in the desert as aesthetics or
they're hanging from baskets and you
know they cause themselves pain and deny
themselves in order to be filled up by
God and they have a lot of time to think
about and reconcile some of these
questions and I found that going through
that process actually strengthened my
faith and you know the the belief in
this unifying thing that we don't need
government in order to feel and express
and you know it's actually government
it's it's not libertinism that has
weakened that social fabric it's this
idea that oh I pay taxes therefore I
don't have to go to Turks like I don't
have to donate money I don't have to you
know give five dollars to a homeless guy
because I pay tax like your taxes
Oh to pensions you know your taxes are a
magnet for corruption that is not
distributed honorably so let's talk
about sort of your brand of
libertarianism so let's start with
foreign policy on foreign policy which
brand of libertarian Ares I've heard
Larry elder is a very hawkish brand of
libertarian and then you have sort of
the Ron Paul libertarianism which is
that the United States should absolutely
minimize its military and that we're too
active around the world so where are you
I think we are too active around the
world I don't know why we have so many
bases open and then people save shipping
lanes and that's all they say so you
know people accept these premises
without really doing any investigation
and I'm always open to having my mind
changed and if I have a smart person
who's got a rational view of why should
we we should be doing something specific
in a certain part of the world I'm more
than willing to listen to that and to
have my mind changed in you but I think
when we err toward peace and capitalism
because those two things to me are
inextricable that's when we are better
off and that's and you have fewer dead
people and fewer poor people and I think
ultimately that's a much better equation
is is there space for creation of free
markets and capitalism without an
interventionist America meaning that the
argument made I've made the argument
myself on behalf of intervention ISM is
not that we should that anybody wants
military conflict but that if we are not
protecting shipping lines to take an
example then the Russians of the Chinese
are interfering with shipping lanes and
then shifting those to their own
economic benefit typically to the effect
of strengthening communism if you're
China right if you're trying to take
over the South China Sea and then move
all those countries into your sphere of
influence that they will trade with you
and not with the United States and
affect their governments that they're
friendlier to you and your repression of
a billion people then you know that
that's a that's a problem I understand
that but that's that's what leads to the
slippery slope of the United States
being interventionist and reactionary
and then all of a sudden you have
Afghanistan like what's to present
what's to prevent rather the next
Afghanistan in some place like Iran and
there's no endgame and there's also no
victory victory
is actual free trade victory is
individuals making choices for
themselves and if that means building a
supply chain and a factory in Vietnam
versus China where there's arguably more
economic freedom now then there is a
mainland China then I'm fine with that
but I don't think that's up to the
government that those decisions are up
to the individual and we spend so much
on the military yet we deny the warriors
what they really need because the
military is a lot like academia and that
there aren't a lot of great professors
and professors aren't the ones who are
served learning is not served just like
warriors are not served and freedom is
not served it's the administration and
that's what gobbles up these giant
budgets and in both aspects you have
unfettered spending and there is no
incentive for either institution to cut
down that's a I mean that's an argument
for smarter spending that I think
everyone hawkish endevours should be
able to get on board with I mean wasting
money on golden toilets I don't think is
anything that anybody may be in favor of
so for people in the military who will
II truly believe in fighting form
protecting freedom they are the ones
that I've had the most interesting
conversations with about cutting
spending because there are ways to do
that that don't make you unpatriotic it
doesn't mean that you despise the
military or that you vilify people who
wear the uniform it's quite the opposite
is there a deterrent effect to having a
powerful strong military and a
willingness to intervene meaning that
there there are two ways that the United
States ends up in war typically one is
that we intervene in places that are not
necessary and we've seen that from
everywhere from from Libya to to perhaps
Iraq given the information being wrong
as was then the other way that you end
up in a war is that you end up basically
retreating from the world and somebody
fills the vacuum and suddenly you find
yourself in a war because they've used
that as a launching off point which
actually was what happened in
Afghanistan for example yes and and I
think there's a difference between
isolationism and anti interventionism
and we can find that balance we're smart
enough and we're capable of
having difficult conversations you know
what worries me or actually people on
the Left who have now grown very hawkish
who don't have great regard for human
life who I think would get us into worse
conflicts and you know I actually I'm
much more interested in the policy
positions of people like people who to
judge until see Gabbard who have you
know been in war zones and they've seen
the cost of war firsthand and it doesn't
make you weak to strive for peace I
would hope that everybody is striving
for peace I think that the balance is
one between deterrence and
interventionism nobody actually wants to
intervene but the credible threat of
force is obviously a necessary part of
foreign powers virtually that's it
that's a large gray area and that's
where I am most skeptical because
whenever I don't care if it's climate
hysteria or military hysteria you know
you always have to be very careful when
someone is selling you a bill of goods
in a led briefcase to take a couple of
examples right now obviously we're
watching it Taiwan has been threatened
by by China for four years what would
you do about Taiwan I mean is that a
situation where we should be signaling
to the Chinese that we are willing to
supply the Taiwanese with what they need
for resistance if China should do
something or is that a situation we
should say that's very far away that
really doesn't have anything to do with
us they're on their own I don't think
that I don't think that China's going to
get into a hot war with Taiwan I mean I
look at it like the stimulus spending
you know we were bamboozled into two
stimulus packages because what happens
if we don't do anything the exact same
thing is if we do something only we save
a bunch of money and you know they're we
save a bunch of lives and is it worth
making gold star families in Taiwan no
but should we show China that we are
allies and always on the side of freedom
absolutely and I think you know if if
China were going to press the issue they
would have done it so far in Hong Kong
and they're doing it subversively but
not as actively as we would fear no
we'll wait to see how things end up in
Hong Kong we don't know how it's going
to end up in Hong Kong or North Korea so
let's talk about another aspect of
libertarianism that
come up so you've seen this argument
among libertarians about abortion about
the the state's role in protecting
unborn lives so as a social conservative
but also as a libertarian to me that's
not even a libertarian issue if you
believe this is a nun if you believe
this is a human life then yeah
libertarians also believe that the state
has a role in protecting human is also a
Ron Paul you know belief and I think
there is something very valid to that
that whatever makes us uniquely human is
implicit in our DNA it's not something
that just happens when a fetus is viable
or an infant is viable because a
three-year-old is not viable
you know therefore is it acceptable to
terminate the life of a three-year-old
when they become an inconvenience
absolutely not
that is murder so you know the idea of
viability is a very slippery slope I
like that abortion has been going in the
down direction I like that people that
women are thinking about it seriously
and you know there are a multitude of
ways to engage in adoption that people
didn't realize were open to them before
because it was very scary and nebulous
twenty or thirty years ago and now it's
possible to have an open adoption where
both sides both sides meet each other
and they know each other that happened
in my family and my mom and the adopted
mom are very close friends and they have
always been in each other's lives and
it's it's beautiful right so you are
also an early advocate of same-sex
marriage and that one libertarian seem
to be pretty consistent about they say
that the state has no role in in
marriage now do you believe that the
state should be giving the same benefits
to same-sex couples they give to married
couples or the state should give no
benefits to any couples and it's none of
the state's business I feel like the
state should be giving no benefits to
any couples and I'm sure that sounds
very heartless but oh no I'm with you
yeah your heterosexuality is not a
precursor for state-sponsored benefits
do you see the case so the case for
conservatives always was that the state
does have an interest in the production
and rearing of children that without a
future generation that there is no
that there's nobody pay the taxes
there's nobody to actually but if I
because if the government wasn't tapping
you on the shoulder going hey how babies
hi babies people would still have baby I
mean this is why I'm on your side you're
gone but it's a miraculous thing because
people will still have children you can
really screw with families by having a
one-child policy like they've had in
China and if you remember after the
earthquake when that school was crushed
in China there were families that were
completely obliterated because their one
child was killed in that natural
disaster so on same-sex marriage so just
to clarify is that a libertarian
position governmentally or a libertarian
position morally meaning that there this
is always one one area where
conservatives tend to butt up against
libertarians but why who cares who gets
married
I just officiated a wedding between two
men who love each other and it's like
love to me is like the ultimate
manifestation of heaven on earth like
God created love God is love and if you
find that with another human being and
your heart tells you that you have found
your other half and you've connected
with that person Who am I to judge like
I don't care let's party so it's not a
government I can explain hey it's not a
governmental level I totally agree with
you meaning that if you want to perform
a same-sex marriage have at it on a
moral level obviously as a religious Jew
I feel very differently
just let me not only on a religious
level I think they're their natural law
reasons to oppose same-sex marriage but
not on a governmental level I don't
think you can make a solid libertarian
case for why the government should be
even involved in this thing and at all
which is why I've always suggested that
one of the happy coincidences of
libertarianism is you can disagree about
some of the core issues in life and
still leave each other alone
exactly and that's that's what's so
funny is like you really can and you
just go yeah that's fine and what's
amazing to me as I look around at the
people you know whether it's relitigated
the Cavanaugh accusations or talking
about impeaching the president and
assuring in president number 46 Mike
Pence which you know will happen is a
natural consequence of impeachment which
is very funny is people are so deeply
personally hurt by the outcome of the
election and you know
got friends at captain Panera always
joking like try being a libertarian I
said when's the last time one of my
candidates won anything so that's what
I'm asking about next what why can't
libertarians get their act together
meaning that may be a great question but
we've been hearing about the libertarian
wave for literally years yeah the future
of the moment right there will be a
libertarian moment Rand Paul will emerge
from the shadows and suddenly be the
Republican presidential candidate and of
course he flames out within the first
three weeks of the campaign
you know why is that libertarian moment
so long and coming if it's so obviously
and eminently true is the question I
don't know and and you know it's it's
really frustrating because I'm not a
member of the libertarian party but
obviously they run a lot of candidates
that I am ideologically aligned with and
the only thing I can think of is so much
politics today is emotion and hyperbole
and it's it's rationalism is a really
tough sell in this climate so we need we
need better marketing I don't know if
you've seen these sort of studies that
demonstrate the number of people who are
socially liberal and socially can and
and fiscally liberal socially liberal
and fiscally conservative socially
conservative and fiscally conservative
the smallest number of people among
those groups are people who are socially
liberal and fiscally conservative it's
very popular in New York is very popular
in LA even people who tend to be
fiscally liberal like to pretend that
they're fiscally conservative there when
it comes to spending but it is a very
small number of people who consider
themselves both socially liberal and
fiscally conservative why do you think
there is this this culture gap between
the codes in the middle of the country
on this particular issue among
conservatives particularly you know why
because people on the coasts have never
had someone bring them a casserole when
they're sick and in the middle of the
country that's just what you do and
people don't think twice about it you
know people will go ahead and bring you
two jars of jam when they make
strawberry jam or when the candor
peaches and it's a lovely thing my
family is from southern Indiana and I
take my girls there every year so they
can get a hit of real hospitality and
you know it's like life is is it's a
little simpler and it's a little bit
slower and people take time to talk to
each other and it's it's not it's not as
rushed and it's not as self
and people wave it's funny because you
can be running and I have a friend from
Minnesota and we joke that like you can
be running in Los Angeles and people
don't look at each other but in the
Midwest like you see someone you're like
even if you don't know oh it freaked me
out I was in Oklahoma I mean I spent my
entire life in LA and I was in Oklahoma
you know I mean you know because you're
from LA you walk down the street you
don't want to catch eyes with somebody
they might kill you if you walk down the
street in Oklahoma and you catch right
like the first time I was in Oklahoma I
walked down the street caught eyes with
somebody and she goes oh hey hello yeah
and I told my father I was like I don't
know what's going on here what's wrong
with these people
there is that there's this very
different feel and it you know it's
something I think people in big cities
are really missing I was discussing yeah
my wife just even being in New York it's
like a nice place to visit not sure that
I'd want to bring up kids here I mean
how how his family life having to live
over on this coast it's really you know
it was all sort of encapsulated by my
daughter who is my youngest daughter
who's six when we moved here and she
said I think because there were a lot of
homeless people in our neighborhood
because I think I have an idea how some
of those homeless people can get houses
and I was like Talmadge goes they need a
bigger bucket for more money and I said
that's a great start because then they
can go to CVS and get a pair of
flip-flops so they have shoes because
she noticed that a lot of the homeless
people didn't have shoes I'm like that's
great and then when she goes then they
take the bucket to the max store and
they get a Mac and then they go look for
an apartment on the Mac I'm like problem
solved but it actually makes children
very empathetic because they see so much
of life in humanity and they're not as
fearful of other people but they're more
aware and they have to be more
self-sufficient by nature and I think
the world benefits from empathy and
self-sufficiency because in
helicoptering we've deprived children of
that you know of the joy of discovering
their own communities and kind of
fending for themselves you know it's
like when you have kids in New York they
have to look out for other people like
you have to be able to tell the
difference between a good guy and a bad
guy and you know you tell your kids if
you ever get in trouble find a mom with
other kids or a copper a firefighter and
have them call me
so what do you make any switching topics
but what do you make of the the rise of
populism so there's been this rise
populism on the Left that's it's really
a strategy more than than a basket of
policies yeah but on the right you've
seen this rise of populism I blame as
forum I've been I've been really
disturbed by it to see that this kind of
big government conservatism supposed
conservatism that is that has come to
the forefront this idea that frankly
president from campaigned on in 2016
that he was going to bring all the jobs
back to Indiana and Ohio by levying
tariffs and by granting subsidies this
idea that government is here to save you
from yourself and you see there's this
wide gap even on Fox News between
various commentators on this sort of
stuff what do you make of the rise of
the big government conservative and do
you think that that's a durable message
for the future considering that
basically Bush was a big government
conservative the same way the trumpet
they all were yeah and and you can
always tell the populist by how much
they spend and what they veto and what
they don't veto and you know ultimately
I think it's very anti individual which
means it's anti creativity and it's it's
so overbearing and it's just as bad on
the right as it is on the left and when
government is making choices for you we
all lose so let's talk about healthcare
for a second is this obviously become a
key issue for both the right and the
left people on the left suggesting that
health care is right people on the right
basically giving in to that yeah that's
isn't that problematic it is to me I
mean nothing that has ever been declared
a right in in positive fashion has ever
gotten cheaper or more competitive yeah
it is things that are commodities that
get cheaper and more competitive because
people provide commodities for price
whereas things that our rights are pried
away from you against your will
generally unless you're talking about
just a right to be free of somebody else
doing something to you
but what we but that line between
positive rights and negative rights has
been completely blurred and I blame the
left for that and I blame the right for
not standing up to it and and not saying
no health care and health insurance are
services those are services that you pay
for it that someone's got to pay for and
you're gonna pay for it one way or the
other I don't want you robbing me of my
tax money for your bad decisions and
that may sound heartless but when people
have less accountability they're going
to naturally make worse decisions and
you have to try
people to make better decisions and
magically they will but with health care
I was having a conversation with the
woman the other day and said health
insurance companies should not be for
profit and I said why like I don't care
if it means that I get cheaper health
insurance that's great that's not the
problem the problem is the insurance
companies and the health care providers
working in concert with each other
masking prices and masking choices
that's one of the bigger institutional
issues the fact that you don't know what
things cost before you have the service
so if your insurance decides not to pay
for something you're on the hook for it
the second you get a bill a bill is a
contract and people don't know that they
can negotiate stuff beforehand so if we
adjusted some of our systems to engage
and a little bit more negotiation
everyone would be better off because
they would be able to make informed
choices about who they seek care from
and what they're willing to spend money
on so this becomes one of the issues
where people have very strong critiques
of libertarianism specifically with
regard to say people who are too sick
can't pay for their own health care they
have a pre-existing condition so you've
seen Republicans cave in on the idea
that they need to force insurance
companies to cover pre-existing
conditions which is like forcing fire
insurance companies to cover burn down
houses yeah but so what if you got in
the car accident and totaled your car
and then you went up to Geico and said
hey can you insure my car they'd be like
no right so what do we do with people
who have pre-existing conditions how do
we how do we help take care of those I
think there are there are some companies
that that will and should provide for
that I don't think you should force
every insurance company to cover
pre-existing conditions and I don't
think you should force every single
person to buy an insurance policy where
they have maternity and Rehab covered I
think we should have catastrophic
policies which we don't anymore and
that's not what insurance is for and
that is what is allowed basically you
know the private insurance industry to
run like Medicare so there's been a
whole critique of libertarianism from
the sort of behavioral economics school
so there's the classical economics
school which basically treats every
individual as hell no economists we're
going to make rash
decisions and even if essential for you
specifically it's true for the majority
of people over time the rational
decisions will be made people will act
in their own economic self-interest and
then there's a group of behavioral
economist and they say well that's
actually fantasy that most people are
going to act as a result of emotional
response they're going to react not in
terms of their own best interest and
this undermines the premises of
libertarianism so to take a practical
example when you talk about drugs
so libertarians say okay well listen you
choose to get hooked on a drug that's a
you problem
you've got to handle that one yourself
that's not my problem that's not anybody
else's problem and not only that if the
government tries to get involved and
stop you from getting those drugs it's a
violation of Liberty that basically
they're stopping you from getting
something that you want to get the the
behavioral economists would say well but
people who get addicted to drugs don't
have much of a choice and then buying
the drug for the rest of time you're
addicted to heroin it's not as though
you're sitting there and making an
economic calculation about whether
another hit of heroin is going to be
good for you or yes but what if you
could make a calculation as to what was
in the drug you were taking then I think
you would see fewer overdose deaths
because if you have a black market you
know that's the ultimate opacity you
don't know what you're putting in your
body even if you're the most rational
person in the world so if you were able
to seek the substance that you wanted
and you knew what you were putting into
your body the chances of you putting
something deadly in there are much much
lower so that might stop hope your
deaths but but there's the other problem
which is it could also stop overdoses
which don't always lead to deaths right
putting aside even the most catastrophic
cases of overdoses or death let's talk
about the the innervation of people
their inability to work inability to to
get a job or to think rationally about
many many issues yes is there an anti
libertarian case with regard to the drug
war simply on the basis of you've
actually deprived people of their own
agency or they've deprived themselves of
their agency and now they've become
Ward's of the rest of society no but
funding the drug war has deprived people
of their agency and that you know half a
million people have died and that's too
many you know you've got people who are
murdered massacred by cartels because
although the drug war deals with this
supply kind of it doesn't even do a good
job of that but
there seems to be plenty of workarounds
and I went to the El Chapo trial several
times and listened to the testimony and
it was fascinating when they were
talking about the creative ways they got
drugs into this country and it had
nothing to do with the border wall they
would find vehicles and fruit cans and
and everything else it's the demand and
your drug war is not going to touch
demand and there are people who are
going to put substances in their body
and the government arbitrarily decides
that this substance is bad but this one
is just fine and you have people who are
killing themselves in a myriad of ways
so do you think there's any distinction
among drugs at all or just blanket
libertarian policy on all drugs no I
think there is a distinction but I don't
think that marijuana deserves to be
scheduled with heroin and meth is that
the distinction between heroin and meth
and marijuana I think it's an important
distinction I think that we should start
you know and we're going to have to
tackle drug policy incrementally because
it doesn't make a lot of sense to just
throw open the pharmacy cabinet and say
hey kids have at it you know and as
individuals and as parents of course
that's not what we want and that's not
what people are pushing for but when you
have a massive black market that's when
people are forced into criminal activity
and you know they say marijuana is a
gateway drug marijuana is a gateway to
drug dealers drug dealers are the ones
who have drugs it's the only people
smoke weed for the first time and
they're like oh man I got to go get some
ecstasy and then I got to get some meth
and then you know top it off with a
little bit of heroin that's not how it
works and the the people who do have an
addiction that is crippling those are
people who should be able to get help so
over and the behavioral economist would
tell you that that basket is much fuller
than the classical economists would so
overall let's shift to kind of
modern-day politics President Trump
obviously elected with a minority of the
popular vote but with a with a large
majority of the electoral college vote
how do you think that he has
performed as president you have to give
him a grade it depends on what it is
because his grades are all over the map
like you know he's pretty good in math
he's he's like a C student in history
and you know maybe like a c-minus in
English and he doesn't he doesn't have
just one grade and that's the
interesting thing because it really is
the first postmodern presidency and
we're experiencing it in a number of
ways at the same time and that's that's
a very bizarre thing and it's up to
voters to separate his policies from his
personality because his personality at
times can be very distracting to the
point of being annoying and unbearable
but then his policies and his swerve
into deregulation and tax cutting that's
all great it's incomplete but that part
is satisfying if he can do more of that
it's all good but if if he distracts
everyone with his stupid pronouncements
and tweets and impulsivity then it's
just a question of whether or not a
majority of people get tired of that and
they no longer want to make the
separation between the two so when
President Trump was elected I was
concerned about a few things I was
concerned about his policies which have
been much more conservative than I
thought they would be because who the
hell knew where he was gonna be and then
I was concerned that he was gonna soul
sucked the Republican Party to be the
party of tariffs and the party of big
government and that's sort of happened
sort of but not completely they were
already the party that was tending
towards some of those things and then I
was concerned that he was going to
the ability of a non democratic
party a republican party to win young
voters minorities women and that's the
one where I feel most fulfilled
unfortunately what do you make of the
critique of President Trump that in the
long term that the wins that we've
gotten on policy may not outweigh the
losses that we experience electoral I
think things happen so quickly and so
much can happen between now and November
you know we still got 14 months until
the election and if the economy
continues to improve
I do think that
a sort of Captain America shield for him
and you know it allows him to defend
against the slings and arrows of his own
making I I don't buy into the idea like
african-american employment unemployment
and asian-american unemployment is at an
all-time low therefore I'm not racist
it's like I don't I don't know that
those two things are directly correlated
and I think Michael Goodwin in the New
York Post had a really great analysis of
this after the most recent presidential
debate and he said there were no winners
the Democrats are so lackluster there's
no one who can take on the president but
the president can absolutely destroy his
own chances of reelect ability so let's
take a look at the Democratic Party for
a second so it's turned into a complete
a horror show over there there used to
be some people over there who are even
mildly interesting yeah Elizabeth Warren
back in 2003 was actually mildly
interesting believed in school choice
and all of this and now she's decided to
go Bernie white and why do you think
that the Democratic Party has moved so
radically in this really unattractive
direction I mean all they had to do was
not be crazy it appears that they have
not been able to resist the impulse no
and it's its head shaking for people
when beta or org stands on the debate
stage and says you're AB you know you're
coming after your guns it's like how
dumb do you have to be how politically
inept do you have to be to say something
like that and you know I don't think
that guy knows that trigger from a
muzzle I really don't and you know it's
interesting cuz Peabody judge had to
kind of correct him there and Elizabeth
Warren while I don't agree with her on
most things I do think the fact that she
has been staking out you know very
surgically her policy positions over a
number of years just speaks to her
political intuition and and she is the
most politically intuitive person there
I don't know that that she has the
killer left hook necessary to end the
nomination process and you know Joe
Biden isn't going anywhere and it seems
like the press is having a field day
just tallying up his gaffes day
today speech after speech you know it's
like Joe Biden couldn't remember the
word escalator you know it's like no
matter what the headline is for the day
and if the president just stood back a
little bit you know maybe gave us
another tax cut you know God forbid
tackle the entitlement reform maybe got
a couple things passed in terms of
health care and price transparency and
the few things that he's talked about he
would be in better standing and more
people would feel good about that and
you know I - a lot of people in the
middle of the country and a lot of the
women I times were like I can't stand
them he drives me crazy but there's no
way I'm voting for a socialist I mean
when you look at the Democratic Party
then if you were gonna handicap this
race do you think that more emerges or
do you think the Biden is able to stick
this thing out I don't know I mean just
over the past couple weeks
you know Biden got past all the the
weird sort of pseudo sex stuff and then
you know he had his eye explode in the
gaffes and the teeth and everything like
that and you know he's still there but
he's only going in one direction and
it's not up whereas Elizabeth Warren is
really figuring out and and her brain is
interesting because she's obviously a
person who understands systems and so
she's figuring out systems and where
people have failed and where their
inconsistencies are and she makes
herself more consistent and calmly
Harris hasn't been able to do that I
thought komal Harris would be that
candidate I thought she would be the
more analytical shrewd candidate and and
she's really kind of fallen off the map
yeah her her collapse has been
astonishing to watch because he really
thought after that first debate okay
well now she was gonna make a move into
Biden's share of the black vote and then
she'd wrap it up that's really Elizabeth
Warren's hole in the electorate is the
fact that there's not a single black
person the country apparently who
supports Elizabeth Warren and everybody
supports Biden because he was stapled to
Obama's pant leg but now we're gonna see
how that plays out so looking forward to
the 2020 election let's say that that
Biden is the nominee you say that the
economy is going to be sort of sword and
shield for president Trump obviously if
the economy tanks he's in serious
trouble
which candidate among the Democrats you
think stacks up best against Trump and
not heard from preferred the Democrat in
terms of the akan
your justice just general election I do
I do think it's Warren I think there are
more people I think the more that
Elizabeth Warren emerges Bernie Sanders
kind of fades and people still have
great affection for him and they do love
his authenticity they love that he
really believes in what he's talking
about even though they may disagree with
the means to get there and Elizabeth
Warren everyone smells like more I like
capitalism and it's like no you don't
know one of those you didn't build that
people she absolutely is so you know and
I don't you don't even have to get into
her fake heritage to to find some flaws
with her but I do think she has filled
the establishment gaps as well and the
fact that she is willing to help out in
the down ballot races and that she's
gone to the Democrat Party and said I
will give you all of my donors and all
of my email lists and everything else
even if I'm not the nominee and that
makes them more likely to support her
and you know the subtext Roy's so one
more libertarian question for you one of
the areas that conservatives and
libertarians are really at odds over
criminal justice reform a lot of folks
who are conservative myself included
well I'm very skeptical of the these
sort of we're going to restructure a
criminal justice and release huge
numbers of prisoners onto the streets
yes there are some people who are in
jail for possession I'm fine with those
people mopping in jail for possession
yeah but the fact is that the vast
majority of people who are in prison are
not in jail for for possession they're
there for drug dealing or they're there
for violent crime and the rehabilitation
levels for people are exceedingly low
people people have extraordinarily high
recidivism rates so they they do for
things like rape and sexual assault and
child sexual abuse and things like that
and I think those people are monsters
and they should not be walking the
streets there are homeless people who
are mentally ill and they should not be
in prison yes agreed
I mean and is that by the way is that is
that a place where the government should
be active when it comes to taking care
of the mentally ill for example so you
see huge populations of the homeless in
New York City where I'm gladder I would
rather see homeless people given choices
and given treatment and not and
voluntarily committed
that has become a popular trend lately
and as a libertarian I could never get
on board with that but I do think there
are ways of treating people and I think
there are more humane ways of treating
people than allowing them to live in
their own feces and filth in tents on
public sidewalks I think it is
disgusting and I think that Eric
Garcetti should be ashamed of himself
that he has allowed his city to
malignantly become and mutate into
something like that I mean I will admit
I am an advocate for involuntary
involuntary treatment for people who are
seriously mentally ill my grandfather
was a paranoid schizophrenic and if
there had not been you know if if it had
been up to him he would have been trying
to hang himself on a routine basis and
thinking the radio spoke to him and so
it was only through treatment that he
was able to get better a lot of people
who are severely mentally ill do not
simply they really do not have the
capacity why I'd rather see people like
that receive treatment than
medicare-for-all or the green New Deal
you know people who have health
insurance we should not be diverting
money in public programs to people who
can seek gainful employment but to
people who truly are incapacitated
that's you know if you're going to have
a safety net that's where it should go
so earlier you mentioned entitlement
reform and you sort of among the list of
things you think president room should
do President Trump campaign in 2016 I
never ever touch I know it sucks yes and
that's that's a complete wish list of
mine that has no basis in Trump reality
I'm wondering I mean listen I'd love
entitlement reform to so would Paul Ryan
but the question is whether that has
basis in any reality for the American
people is whether you think that's
something that the American people will
ever get behind when Bush tried to touch
it after 2004 it basically ended his
term his second term yet nothing done
from there on it do you think that the
American people have any desire or taste
for entitlement reform or is this thing
going to go all the way down to
austerity cuts and it's going to go to
austerity absolutely because no one's
gonna have the nards to tell old people
especially because that's the worry is
if you tackle the entitlement monster it
means that you're you know stopping
checks to retirees who don't have any
savings and that's you can't have a
system that works like that you know
because you
can't just abandon the most vulnerable
but also old people vote so I think I
think that's what most politicians are
scared of so I have one final question
for Kennedy that is what is the biggest
problem facing the country also I want
her opinion on sex robots yes that's
that's actually going to come up but if
you want to hear her answer you have to
be a daily wire subscriber to subscribe
go to daily wire calm and click
subscribe kennedy thanks the ben shapiro
show sunday special is directed by
mathis glover and produced by jonathan
hey executive producer Jeremy Boren
Associate Producer Colton Haas our
guests are booked by Caitlin Maynard
post-production is supervised by Alex
Zingara
editing by Donovan Fowler audio is mixed
by Mike Hiromi no hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera title graphics by Cynthia
Angulo the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
[Music]